yeah doesn't about dashing babies
against rocks that's in the Bible that's
in the Bible in happy is the one who
sees his infants and dashes them against
the Rocks this is in the Bible isn't me
Dash them against the
Rocks when you're in yeah yeah there's
nothing wrong with that what's WR what's
WR how you how you comparing me having
72 wives to a baby being dashed against
rocks this is a direct command look this
is a direct commandment of God it says
go to amalekites look Jesus is saying
the god of the Old Testament go to
amalekites because what they did to you
kill men women children babies and
donkeys it clearly says that to
[Music]
you we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah subhana
tala in the country of Norway click on
the link and donate now for the sake of
Allah subhana tala about
is people like to also twist Islam to
use it for violence like people yeah
many it happens with Christianity you
got the KKK you got the nice resistant
Lo resistant Army in Africa uh you've
got that guy who went and shot up
Muslims in New Zealand he was a of a
Christian you've got George Bush who
killed most prominent in Islam No not
you the only reason you say that is
because you hear that no but it's it's
evident for example look at any
statistics in history the biggest amount
of people who have killed mass amount of
atrocities as atheist then it's
Christians day no even present day give
me give me give me show me show me any
statistic that show that Muslims have
perpetrated more acts of terrorism than
uh Christians or atheist for that matter
in the UK anywhere yeah anywhere there
isn't this is this is it's like this is
no there isn't I'm not saying I'm just
saying what do you guys think about that
you guys like push against no but the
point is this you have been made to
believe that is true that's why when I
tell you you're in a shock you're like
it cannot be because that because it's
been like for example knife crime knife
crime happens on a daily basis but when
media starts covering it you start
getting scared oh my gosh hello knif
crime has happening for a long time they
are covering it more now that's why
you're more scared but it's always been
happening yeah when it comes to this
like the thing is we say like there is
nothing in Islam that tells you to go to
innocent people contrary to that very
interestingly the Bible for example is
the only scripture that gives you direct
commandment this is why Israel is doing
what they're doing and they're quoting
amalik have you've seen Benjamin
Netanyahu he goes and remember what
amalik did to you have you heard of him
say that do you know who he's talking
about amalik is mentioned in the Old
Testament in the book of Samuel it says
go and kill this was an order by God
Almighty in in the uh in the Bible to go
kill men women children and babies there
is not a single verse in the Islamic
entire literature that tells us to go
innocent men women children it is
clearly forbidden by the prophet
Muhammad when you go to Warfare to kill
uh attack place of worship monks uh
rabbis uh people who are innocent you
are not allowed to harm trees we don't
have anything like that in our
literature but of course there are bad
Muslims I'm not going to I'm not going
to deny they are I'm saying like the
terrorist ideology the ideology that you
need to free like make sure the world is
pure you know I mean like that like
fight for your religion
that I I'm telling you look I'm not
looking if I'm lying how we you need to
protect your religion is what does
protect your religion mean from what in
the Quran I'm pretty sure I'm protecting
my religion Now by answering this
conception people come here and say oh
your ReliOn says kill everybody I'm like
no it doesn't so you're talking about
Jad are some very question no of course
there are no don't get twisted I'm not
here to say my religion is just all like
peace and throw flowers no there is when
is war is war believe me I'll be in the
front lines yeah cuz war is meaning what
that if you are dealing with people who
are oppressed or if for example you
being attacked you are allowed to Jihad
you're talking about Jihad yeah Jad is
in the Quran you agree with the entire
Quran yes of course 100% 100% in the
Quran it tells you specific verses
dealing with specific individuals so
where it says for example wherever you
find them Smite it says there's a verse
in the I'll tell you it says Smite their
necks and every joint yeah do about
dashing babies againsts that's in the
Bible that's in the Bible in I think
it's the Book of Numbers it's in the
Bible nowhere in the Quran in the Bible
it tells you when you go to read that
online there is say something straight
Direction it's not my work where's my
phone can I use your
phone the thing is with the Bible I feel
like it's more it's telling a story
whereas the Quran is straight preaching
no because what you're hearing is is is
um prescriptive not descriptive it's
prescribing you what to do wait
wait the B the Bible tells stories that
we meant to take things from I mean take
a quote out of a Bible saying that
someone did something to someone like
say someone raped someone right that's
not saying the Bible prohibits that it's
just telling a story of that happening
no no no if you read 1 Samuel 15: 2 to3
it gives you a direct commandment by
Jesus who's the god of the Old Testament
to go to amikit the which is Jesus you
believe you don't believe Jesus Is God
so who's the god of the Old Testament
Jesus yeah but Jesus comes in through in
the New Testament that's fine but you
but you do believe he's part of the
godhead yeah I believe there's one and
only God the holy trity good so we say
God the Father God the Son and the god
the Holy Spirit yeah okay so that same
God is the god of the Old Testament he's
the one that's prescribing Moses to go
and kill amalik kill male women children
or babies it's the book of Psalms 13
verse and then it says means when it
says happy is the one who seizes infants
and bashes them against the Rocks this
is in the Bible yeah but what does it
mean you have against the no this is an
article on what it means it's found in
go to another one I can go to Bible
Gateway no like if you go up to the
website you're just on it's going to
tell you what it means oh okay no no no
it's it's this is prescription of War so
you know Warfare there's war ethics in
in the Quran we have War ethics we
cannot harm innocent men women children
babies trees we are not allowed to harm
uh churches or synagogues yeah but
fighting men fighting like fighting men
if a man a man is fighting that's normal
so if you go to the King James
[Music]
version it says happy shall be the one
that taketh and dasheth the little ones
against Stones this is telling you we
know when you armies would invade and
they will kill men women it's telling
you what to do with infants nothing like
this is ever mentioned in the Quran
that's why I don't know if you saw a
YouTube video where there was someone he
he um he he he he got the Bible and he
put the cover of the Quran on it and he
was reading passages and there people
like oh my God the Quran is violent no
it's actually the Bible so these kind of
um legislation is in the in the Bible
nowhere in the Quran it tells us it's
very clear we are not allowed to Har
inent people you found it yeah to
understand of this verse I like it the
background is the Jewish people call
upon God to exact Revenge upon their
military enemies that's not Jews Jews
were cast out by God as people who
didn't accept Jesus okay but what's that
got to do with the prescriptive
description of what to do with your
enemies well they didn't that that's the
Jews and they're with they're calling
upon God to do that to their enemies
we're not Jewish no no no you don't need
to be Jewish the point is this who is
prescribing that Jesus who is god of the
Old Testament yeah but Jesus didn't
write the Bible it's from a historical
stand this is what the Jews but is he
not God but is he not God you mean is he
not God for example if I said Allah says
in the Quran go and smash rocks against
the thing Allah Allah says that but not
write the Bible no Allah does not say
that that's what I'm saying I'm saying
yeah he doesn't say that he didn't he
wrote the Bible or he wrote the Quran
I'm not saying he wrote it what I'm
saying is the following is Jesus God
yeah is he the god of the Old Testament
he's just God of everything the old test
I mean Old Testament and the new test
the Old Testament though I never said he
did so what I'm saying is the following
he is ordering and prescribing that yeah
thank you in the Book of Psalms he's
prescribing that when you go I can't be
here for that long no no I'm just two
minutes I I'll just show you I don't 137
is in the context of Jewish Exile in
Babylon where they had been taken as
slaves after the baboni down the city of
Jerusalem the Jews in Exile were then
told to sing us one of the songs of Zion
adding further humiliation and
frustration to defeat people psalmist
recall both the disgraces of I
knowes okay go so so he talking about
Jalem and the bons who destroy their
Capital City comes to two conclusions
and thing first he says happy is the one
who repays you according to what you
have done to us this cry for Revenge
desire the destru so cry it's a cry for
what cry for Revenge so the Jewish
people were attacked and dispelled and
their homes were it's not it's not
saying what they did was wrong right you
know no no no but it's telling them to
do that to the others who is telling you
know what I mean God God look this is
this look you can't just say God is
telling them to do that in the Quan okay
in the Quran Allah tells me to pray who
is that coming from God who is the Old
Testament from from
God look look this is the Bible yeah is
this from God do you believe it to be
from God no I think it's written by
people so it's not from God I I think
God didn't prescribe it the same way
Allah did to Muhammad okay no problem so
is this the word of God or not is this
people okay are they are they men
inspired by God yes okay but they're
writing about things that they went
through it's not necessarily God's
telling them to write their specific no
not write them it's not only just
history it's how we're meant to you know
okay if someone says I have been okay go
and bad things throughout history and
how it meant to go about them okay he's
not necessarily promoting if the Bible
says Go and Kill men women children and
babies yeah but it doesn't say it it
does I can show
you I'm not I'm not making this up I'm
called upon God to do that when they no
I'm taking I'm no no it's not I'm giving
you another I'm giving you first Samuel
to do that look look I'm going to 1
Samuel what was it Psalms 17:9 look let
me just quickly show you here look let
me just quickly show you yeah cuz my
argument is this I'm just saying like
the thing is you can take I can't argue
this cuz I'm not super knowledgeable
right you clear have more knowledge than
me no no no it's it's not having
knowledge it's just with context I could
take things out of the Quran and say it
says explicitly to kill people that
that's what I'm saying so so so with the
Quran there is we we need to look
context I'm saying I want to look at
cont I'm not taking it like that's
that's what I'm saying I can't recite
the entire context of a single statement
in the Bible because it it goes through
loads of sin and thing necessar so you
know like in Babylon yes the the Jews
were kicked out from yeah look it says
very clearly here oh daughter of Babylon
who art to be destroyed happy shall he
be that rewardeth thee as Thou shalt not
serve th happy shall he be the one that
taketh the the little one against the
stone so what is saying is the Jews were
kicked out from a specific place and as
a Revenge okay good so even if you go to
different passages 1 Samuel 15: saying
that the Jews wanted that to happen but
God is not saying that that is okay if I
if I say I if I say I want to kill a
baby if I if I'm if I'm a Catholic and
someone does something horrible to me
and I write I call upon God to like send
them to Hell kill them they God does
that no but he doesn't do that he
doesn't get their babies thrown against
FRS okay okay you say you want to do a
god reveals you can do a to do it if I
do it it's wrong it's sinful it mentions
that in the Bible no nowhere in the
Bible it says that it says look what
you're saying specify directly the Jews
are asking God is approving God is not
saying you are not allowed toing in the
Bible it's not approved okay why does it
say go kill men W children of B I don't
understand that's what the Jews said
that's what they called God to do but
that's not good that's not my friend my
friend if it's not good why did they do
it they they still did it because
they're bad people they're as soon as
Adam and Eve no no no everyone
born if you read your Bible this is a
direct command look this is a direct
commandment of God it says go to
amalekites look Jesus is saying the god
of the Old Testament go to amalekites
because what they did to you kill men
women children babies and donkeys it
clearly says that to you I don't know it
says that it look first Samuel I can
open to you well look even in the Book
of Numbers it gets worse in the Book of
Numbers it says you when you go to
Warfare kill men women and children and
babies and any girl that is a virgin
that hasn't been touched by men keep
them for
yourself okay in the Book of Numbers say
Okay chapter number
31:8 it says when you go to a specific
Nation kill men women or children in
context like I could just say that the
Quran says Uh there's no way go toen you
get 72 women yeah yeah you do what's
wrong with that how how's that killing
babies which okay
as as okay as a perverse okay it's
perverse that as a man that when I go
heaven I'm not going to play piano I'm
going to have 72 virgin who are woman
who are my they they are my like my
wives and I'm going to be with them2
wives when you're in heaven yeah yeah
there's nothing wrong with that what's
wrong what's how you how you comparing
me having 72 wives to a baby being
dashed against rocks one is an innocent
baby one is one is adults having
intimacy against rocks I just read it
to there is look people are watching if
I'm lying look there is context to it
I'm not making this up I know you're I I
don't blame you of course it's to hear
that and to have that your belief system
because I know I know that passage I
brought it up I brought it up I was in
the Quran and the Bible that St that
that passage I'm talking about is
clearly saying to act revenge and this
is happened in the Book of Numbers in
the book of Samuel in Why th the rest of
the Bible does it preach that the
revenge is the only way forward no where
that's you're talking about the New
Testament okay so that's my do you get
what I'm trying to say you're talking
about the New Testament I'm talking
about Jesus
there's many things in the Old Testament
that no no no Old Testament old T is
ruthless Old Testament there's no mercy
bro this ruthless that's why a lot
Christians will come and say oh but that
was the Old Testament we say well that's
still the same Jesus so I'm saying when
we talk about terrorism and all that
kind of stuff bro there is not a single
verse in the Quran that will ever tell
you to kill babies that's that's what
I'm saying with terrorism and stuff like
that you guys stand against that as
stand against what of course not how can
I stand against somebody goes and blows
himself up or runs off innocent people
the reason the reason we set this up my
question for you is such a repeating
thing in Islam why is that it's not
though but what you're saying is Islam
it's like me saying Christians it's like
if you look at the No No but countries
it's very it's very prominent okay I can
come and say okay can you condemn um
your Christian leaders who went to Iraq
and killed 1 million innocent people oh
yeah for sure okay so but it's becoming
a common pattern they did in Afghanistan
and Libya and Palestine no no no that
was Jewish the people that went into
Palestine and stuff like that no no
palese is no no that's no who who
supporting them the Christian Lobby in
America okay Christians are but but do
you get I'm trying to say imagine me
coming and say to you Catholicism that's
that's no imagine me coming and say to
catholism let's call Crusaders America
Christianity I mean the West is
completely like fall no that's what I'm
saying I can't I can't blame you for
what Christians do I'm not I'm asking
why do you think it's very simple
question oh no because they're perverted
individuals most of these individuals
that do this they don't know the where
do you think they get that from cuz they
say they get it from the Quran directly
there there is nowhere in the Quran that
says go and kill innocent people
so there's perverted individuals
everywhere but there are some quot and
that can be twisted yeah there are there
are verses like for example can be
twisted but you have to been absolutely
ignorant because the verse that they use
gives context if you read it uh fully
but I would say that's what I'm trying
to say exactly what you just said can
apply the same to the Bible not the
bible let me tell you not the Bible you
know why because generally I don't have
enough
time thank you thank you thanks for your
time thank you
sister yes there you go guys I'm Islam
net is raising funds to establish a
Masid and Community Center in nor way
and they urgently need your support
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about Islam every youngster
that memorize the Quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
Good Deeds click the link and donate
what you can and share the video for
even extra reward